[Applause]
you know in a lot of my seasonal videos
I often state that it feels as if horror
anime are underrepresented so that's
inspired me a bit why not make a video
on horror anime this time surely there
can't be too few of them right lo and
behold I went back and took a trip down
memory lane realizing that when it comes
to horror as an encompassing genre
there's actually quite a number of shows
that I've enjoyed enough to make a long
list in fact granted Horror in this list
will be used rather Loosely just like
how people tend to easily attribute that
genre to shows with some gore
supernatural beings and such regardless
of whether the Show's actual purpose
would be to induce nightmare fuel or not
still this is what we're going to have
today I'll be listing down my 20
favorite horror anime strap yourselves
in and get ready to see the wide range
and the numerous ways the genre can
provide the so-called Thrills the horror
enthusiasts look for or perhaps they
just have legacies that are hard to
ignore hell girl is here to help us
start out strong
mentioning hell girl reminds me of the
time when this show was pretty popular
there's a lot of Cosplay and it did have
a sizable cultural footprint in its hey
date that much is understandable after
getting a chance to check it out and
knowing what the buzz is all about you
see hell girl is an episodic anime one
which is shown in a case of the day
format one thing connects all cases
however the presence of I enma the
titular hell girl who fer Souls into the
underworld she gets summoned through a
website where victims can set her on the
target at one steep cost even the victim
will suffer consequences and face
Eternal damnation upon his death I mean
that's basically the gist of the story
simple chilling yet very effective in
showing us the darkest depths of the
human heart it's a decent intro into the
psychological horror genre and with
really superb art and sound Direction
that's all you need to get into the mood
for this show we move on with another
show from the mid 2000s Blood Plus
yeah this list isn't all about the anime
that fully lean towards the spooky
aspect of things horror is a pretty
broad genre and it also encompasses
action shows like blood plus if you're
not in the know about this one Blood
Plus is the story of an anemic girl seya
and how she awakens her blood-based
powers after an encounter with a Vampire
together with a rescuer [__] the duo
teams with the organization red shield
to take the fight to the bloodfeeding
monsters it may also be the path to
unlock the miss hisory of se's past
Blood Plus was a fun watch back in the
day it helped provide some darker
alternatives for people who wanted
monster fighting action shows something
which Claymore also provided a year or
so down the line Blood Plus is about the
drama and the emotional impact of
moments as much as it is about the
fighting the premise isn't too unique
even for its time but does the rather
simplistic story really matter if you
can find yourself invested enough in the
action and
[Music]
characters
Shiki is up next on our
list here's our second vampire anime
gracing the list this one however was
released right around the vampire boom
in international pop culture one main
difference is that Shiki doesn't beat
around the bush and portray those
creatures as friendly allies of humanity
it hearkens back to the traditional
tales of the creatures being monsters to
be feared and it opts to go for a
Thriller approach putting vampires as
the main cause of a series of deaths in
a town Ace Dr Ozaki comes up with this
conclusion and it's up to him to
convince the town of the danger before
it's too late now when I mentioned how
it goes back to the roots of the
traditional vampire myth I do mean it in
contrast to something like Vampire
Knight or Rosario Vampire the thing that
stands out is that Shiki brings the
creatures back to their Undead and more
horror leaning Roots like their abor of
sunlight or how they can be killed by
Stakes through the heart when it comes
to the actual content of the anime it
also has no shortage when it comes to
throwing moral and ethical questions at
the audience it's certainly one of the
more introspective horror series out
there following that we have a horror
anime done in a similar vein Ghost
Hunt No Ghost Hunt isn't another story
about vampires nor is it about
investigating a series of deaths in town
what it is though is another horror
series that's more introspective more
intelligent if you will especially in
how carefully it handles the topic of
ghost hunting at least compared to my
expectations it's not nearly as serious
or as dark as Shiki and there's some
moments of light-hearted humor but it's
a show that puts a strong emphasis on
the characters and fleshing them out the
characters have very engaging
interactions with one another and the
arc based format of the show as opposed
to having one big overarching narrative
gives lots of said characters a chance
to shine do take note that for a horror
anime Ghost Hunt isn't scary at all I
don't mean that as a knock on the show
since the world word Horrors used very
Loosely in the world of anime with the
tag being easily slapped onto anything
that has ghosts and demons and such it
does bring the suspense at times but
it's pretty evident that the main point
of focus for the series are the
relationships between the characters and
the Mysteries that a self-contained in
arcs instead of actually giving viewers
nightmares that in spite of the ominous
looking preview
up are you tired of endlessly scrolling
videos that you don't even want to watch
on other social media platforms well say
hello to the sponsors of this video
fresh cut it's the best platform that
was built for creators and their fans
specializing in niches like anime and
gaming by a team that used to work with
twitch and has 20 plus years of combined
experience you can find tons of anime
content creators in fresh cut for
example Yours Truly there's also the
anime wall which has similar features to
Reddit you can find memes answer
questions and whates and even discuss
your hot takes with your favorite
creators not only that I've got a little
surprise for you that you'll certainly
enjoy fresh cut and I are entering a
partnership and to celebrate I'll be
giving away a 3 Monon crunchy roll
subscription to one lucky fan who
comments on my latest wall posts on
fresh cut so be sure to find me there
and take a chance at being the winner
there's also going to be another
giveaway so download fresh cut using the
code Vin tube so that you can enter so
what are you waiting for take a look at
fresh cut now thank you fresh cut and
back to the video we then take a look at
Tokyo
Ghoul needless to say Tokyo Ghoul is the
most popular anime on the list so far
heck I'll even say that it's the most
mainstream the list is going to get
pretty much everyone from almost a
decade ago has been caught in the really
exciting story of how giki's deadly date
introduced him to the world of ghouls
where he slowly comes to grips with his
new Destiny one that involves countless
battles against both Ghouls and humans
as well as an internal battle with
identity Tokyo Ghoul may have had a
polarized reception as with a lot of
popular shows during the time the edgy
and angsty atmosphere also helped
attract the snarkiest of anime fans back
then but what it does do good it does
excellently great soundtrack and action
sequences that dial up the gruesome
nature of the scenes are the anime
speciality and it's Rife with designs
that are both attractive yet also
capture the creepy and monstrous
Aesthetics of the characters
unfortunately it's also a classic
example of adaptation gone wrong as I've
talked about in one of my previous
videos still it's got a load of good in
it in terms of spectacle and it isn't
hard to see why it became popular back
when it first
aired
let's all welcome the first movie in the
list Vampire Hunter
[Music]
D coming from the year 2000 Vampire
Hunter D is a movie that I can recommend
to even people who aren't exactly anime
fans on paper it's a pretty simple
premise d a vampire human hybrid gets
tasked with a mission to rescue a rich
family's daughter who's been kidnapped
by vampires in his quest these flanked
with bounty hunters who have their own
powers serving as his competition as
they take on the creatures of the night
that await them the thing that strikes
out for me with Vampire Hunter D is the
art there's a signature feel to it
befitting the horror and tragedy
elements that embody most of the plot
all that adds to the excellent sound
Direction and The Great action sequences
that Lit to the entire movie it also
doesn't waste time getting you into it
with an opening sequence that many
people have praised to be one of the
best out of anime Cinema in the 2000s
it's almost 2 hours of breathtaking
spectacle it may not seem as impressive
now but when it comes to capturing the
intended atmosphere Vampire Hunter D is
pretty damn
good how about following it up with
another movie
[Music]
paprika
we've had a list so far that features
anime centered on ghosts or other
supernatural creatures so it's time for
a change now you see even if the
monsters go one horrifying element
persists the human psyche for some there
isn't anything in the world more
horrifying than the potentials of the
human mind and paprika is a movie that
takes a surrealist look at the world of
Dreams it's exactly what you'd probably
expect from the premise a detective
story of sworts that puts most of its
eggs in the trippy imagery basket
paprika is a work that you can clearly
tell came from the brains of satosi Kon
there's some impressive visual technique
being shown and the overall theme of the
movie about the power and sanctity of
the human psyche is something we can
ponder on for a while it's not a horror
in the traditional definition but it
does give the creeps when watching it
largely thanks to the imagery and
implications that hit close to home what
[Music]
the Carnage rule super Supreme in the
world of Doro
hedoro right around the start of the
decade I had high hopes of Doro hedoro
after the smoke cleared in the winter
2020 season I'm glad to say that my
hopes weren't unfounded it's indeed a
great adaptation of a source material
that captured the essence of the story
it's gritty it's violent and it's
unrestrained in all of its Madness it
really was unconventional feeling like
an anime that's not exactly designed to
be an anime but one of those crass
Western action cartoons if you get what
I mean mixing dark humor with violence
is the play and mappa knocked it out of
the park both in the story's execution
and the visual Department which
encapsulates The Surreal feel of the
world the series is set him Doro may not
be for everyone and I admit that some
scenes especially the more grotesque
ones can be offputting but anime fans
can be some of the most daring fans in
the world aren't we if you're out for
some dark comedy with a blend of
fighting and unabated violence Doro
hedoro might be worth a
shot
AR Gira is up next and it really looks
like a product of its
time if you're into anime history agira
should be no stranger to you it's one of
the most important anime credited for
the medium's presence overseas it's a
Pioneer in that sense and while there's
a lot to unpack with the movie it's also
a pretty nice take on horror yeah I know
it's not primarily a horror anime like
you'd expect but espers in confinement
letting loose in a dystopian town rif
with violence does have some
uncomfortable connotations it's not an
easy watch for someone not yet attuned
to the medium due to the complicated
plot and the gratuitous violence but you
know what it also led the way for anime
to establish its identity that separates
it from the pack back in the late ' 80s
arira gives a good look of what the
anime scene was like when it tried
making Headway into the Western Market
how different and how uniquely edgy it
was akir is not a perfect movie by any
means but it's Legacy and how
differently and seriously it approached
topics compared to a lot of modern anime
makes it a deserving
[Music]
watch another movie takes this spot
before we reach the halfway point
memories this one not ringing a bell
with you with such a generic name and a
release in the lull period of the '90s
memories is as niche as you can get with
anime that I'll be featuring on this
list what it is in contrast to arira is
a collection of short films done by mad
house yes they were around all the way
back then the three films in this
Anthology all rely heavily on imagery
some creepy than not if we're going to
categorize it as horror it feels more
akin to what paprika is trying to do
rattle the most stoic people with
bizarre visuals which along with the
sounds make it seem as if there's
something un canny something wrong even
if there isn't when you realize that
satos shikon had a hand in the creation
of this movie it all starts to make
sense add the visuals to the underlying
themes and implications given by the
third one of the shorts and then you
kind of have the groundwork for
something which could be considered
unconventional
[Music]
horror if you guess that the next title
is Higurashi take your
cookie
higor Rashi has quite the history pretty
popular back in the days of visual novel
adaptations getting multiple anime
series before a period of silence and a
sudden Revival at the start of the
decade Higurashi in a couple of ways
does remind me of summertime render if
you're looking for a modern comparison
taking place in a rural setting
blanketed by a series of murders and
disappearances Higurashi managed to earn
itself The Horror Attack by being far
far more gratuitous and relishing in its
violence it also can be quite nerving
with how it delivers in its mystery
catching you off guard with the
excessively cute character designs
before things go off the rails horribly
at that even if you know that this is
one of the Gory shows where things go
wrong real quick it's also got a good
way of managing the suspense and keeping
you guessing you know something's going
to happen but you're powerless to stop
it much less know where the trouble's
coming from higari is a show that keeps
you on your toes with its thrilling
Mysteries and depictions of violence and
that's part of the reason why it's
created such a name for itself back in
the era of tear jerker or Roman IC
visual
novels now if you prefer to have your
violence served in a dish of coolness
helling Ultima is here for
you a contemporary of the Higurashi
series Hing ultimate is the OVA series
starring the coolest and most powerful
vampire alukard extermination of his own
kind is alucard's thing and he works
alongside the hell syn organization in
fighting for mankind survival and mind
you the fights can get all sorts of wild
and crazy it's the perfect blend of
badass and Unapologetic Edge for teens
in the era who will especially enjoy the
fights and the finger constantly being
given to deep meanings or morals it's a
simple anime that easily gives the fans
what they want overthe toop anime
carried by the rule of cool when I say
it works it really really works dark
elements swearing a lot of blood scary
yet badass character designs and Power
helling ultimate has it all for its
Target demographic It's a grand
spectacle with a ridiculous overpowered
main character and it's totally honest
with what it's trying to sell to you 10
episodes of this OVA ought to do the
trick if you're one of the people
thirsting for this kind of
content from the 2000s we Zoom to the
present with a pretty promising Hot Shot
zom
Z 100 wasted no time turning heads and
becoming one of the more popular anime
of the Season e to think that it has a
pretty simple plot orbe it with a
context for the main character to catch
it up to speed with the youth culture of
the modern era still even with the whole
droning through life aspect of it at its
core Zone 100's yet another zombie flick
Series so what makes it so special
everything else I'd say the production
values particularly in the art and
animation department just hammers home
the message that this won't just be
another zombie anime it doesn't just
tell you it makes you know this is
something special you're witnessing even
if at its core it really wasn't that's
not meant as criticism of the show as
watching it I find myself thoroughly
entertained the plot moves at a pace
that keeps things exciting and the
characters are a Fun Bunch to follow
while I can concede to an extent that Z
100 is mostly style over substance that
doesn't change the fact that when style
works it works then pack it alongside
some rather thoughtful themes like how
we value life and our self identity and
you've got yourselves a
winner mono gate makes it to the list
because why
not looking at monoke the first thing
that stands out is the art style it's
outlandish and a departure from what
we've become used to in anime the
overall style reminding me of ancient
paintings also helps supplement the
anime which is a collection of short
stories featuring traditional Japanese
Horrors and the medicine Celler main
characters attempts at exercising them
each story is simple monster of the weak
fair but every single one of them has
its own uniqueness to it the strongest
point for the series has to be it sound
Direction which does such a great job in
setting the mood and unsettling even
some of the most hardened anime fans out
of the simplest of scenarios mono gate
may not be the first thing that anime
fans pick out to watch of a seasonal
chart I know I wouldn't that's why I'm
here to give the show a recommendation
and tell you about how good it is it's a
great pit stop in your road to watching
different kinds of anime horror one
that's very Japanese in
essence next in line is
Arin how fitting to put arjin right
after monoke both of them share one
thing in common they're both shows that
people can easily judge based on the
cover while monoke has the traditional
Japanese art going for it arjin has the
CG and we all know full CG shows don't
have a stellar reputation which I think
is a disservice because Arin is a pretty
great show at first glance it may seem
like a typical SN action series but it
has some strikingly good points when we
get a chance to look at the narrative
and the theme surrounding the plot it
has plot points that speak about one's
identity and how it puts One In conflict
with the other so to speak it's not a
rare theme as we already can see with
Tokyo Ghoul a while ago but I do think
that arjin executes it in a
substantially Better Way the plot moves
quickly though making sure that Watchers
will always have something to look
forward to don't let the CG or the other
assumptions fool you arjin may not be
the best or the most thematic action
horror title out there but if I may say
it does pretty well for
itself following that is from the new
world
[Music]
airing in 2012 from the new world was
one of A1 picture's more ambitious works
at the time psychological Mysteries with
a dash of horror tend not to become
mainstream hits but the studio managed a
pretty good outing in adapting this
novel it did end up garnering a good
reputation for itself as time went on
but I'd be lying if I said that people
were lining up to watch Saki and her
friends for inter Sage Academy and their
eventual uncovering of of the psychic
school's Dark Secrets character
development will always remain the
strongest point for the show but I've
also got to give a lot of points for its
way of drumming up the tension and
unveiling horrifying Revelations it
takes a while to rev up but once you get
yourself caught up in the surprisingly
eerie and immersive narrative you
definitely find it hard to let go there
really is something touching to the
heart in seeing the struggles of people
looking to overcome dystopia and that
makes it's a coming of age that you just
got to
see
we have the final movie on the list up
next it's perfect
blue with how hot oshoko has been in the
anime Community alies like me can't help
but recall the days when some anime have
tried tackling the dark side of the
Japanese entertainment industry enter
another satos shikon movie and one of
the darkest examples of those attempts
perfect blue in fact this was the film
that put the guy on the map and it's
really easy to see why just like paprika
it feels different from the usual anime
Fair going completely deep into showing
the dredges of human nature only this
time it's more direct and it's in your
face in terms of showing the darkest
depths of the idol industry there's
little time for lighthearted moments in
this movie and its cynical Outlook may
not be for everyone but it matters as a
piece of work regardless it's a movie
that I think can still speak to the
modern generation the setting and the
art itself may not have aged well but
its power in speaking to to us and
demonstrating its message Still Remains
it continues to paint oblique picture of
humanity with its graphic violence and
sexual themes presented in very serious
ways not like how a lot of anime tend to
trivialize those
elements we head towards the end of the
list and we're doing so in star with
berserk
berserk has been one of the shows that
seems to strongly capture the
imagination of the Teen audience
specifically the edgier and more
rebellious ones it's pretty easy to see
why as berserk is yet another one of
those anime that relishes violence and
taboo there's no room for lightharted
moments here and there's no place for Mo
in the world of Berserk just simple
intense drama and action carried by its
very interesting and superbly
charismatic cast of characters in
addition to the gore and the violence
which likely earned berserk the horror
tag According to some also has no quals
about showing the unglamorous side of
the world an atmosphere that looms over
the story as a whole that much is
evident with how danger seems to lurk in
every corner that no matter how strong
guts in the band of Falcon may be the
next Conquest might just be their last
it's a cynical show that earns some
critical Acclaim thanks to the amazing
handling of themes that some shows
wouldn't even dare approach berserk and
Anime has been a mix bag for the sake of
getting the best experience go for the
1997 one with 25
[Music]
episodes
we're at number two and I think it's
fitting to put promise Neverland in
here promis Neverland and its um
turbulent history as an anime in a media
franchise is a whole Topic in itself it
had the highest of highs becoming a
Smash Hit set to take over the anime
world for years to come to getting a
second season that people wish never
even existed to give context as to why
that was the reaction to the season we
got to first see how great the first
season was the synopsis for the series
is quite interesting and horrifying
children being raised in farmhouses all
for the sake of being fed to Demons was
pretty scary in itself but its true
prowess comes out when you watch the
anime the thing is the horror doesn't
exactly come from the demons who were a
non-presence there wasn't excessive
amount of Gore and there were definitely
not a lot of jump scares but watching
the show you really feel that there's
going to be those elements with how good
the camera cuts are and how the sound
was utilized they're all always seems to
be a lingering feeling hanging over you
and making you expect the worst you'd
always be bracing yourself for the worst
and The Uncanny with each character's
action or Each corner of the character's
turn That's The Power of ambient horror
and promise Neverland simply specializes
in that all while giving us characters
to strongly root for as they plan their
big Escape unfortunately good things had
to come to an end and season 1 was fun
while it lasted honestly what the anime
team did to season 2 was criminal really
makes the first season stand out more in
retrospect and you can still just keep
going back to it and be amazed at how it
mastered its own art of
horror finishing up the list we have
parasite if you're a longtime Watcher of
this channel you know how much I love
parasite as an anime it feels very
complete a complete story some themes
and ideas that make you think about
Humanity's existence amazing action and
a signature soundtrack that gives the
anime its own distinct identity it has
no shortage of gruesome scenes and body
horror mad house really did an awesome
job adapting this old manga and finding
the perfect mix of action and horror and
as I said it's not all about the action
and fighting short the fighting is epic
and one of the main draws of the show
but what really gets me are the themes
that I feel are ever relevant the
development of shinichi and migi's bond
is a joy to watch and the same applies
to the anime scenes depicting the
different spectrums of human nature and
are Ro in this planet as a species
sci-fi and horror at its peak and you
get something like parasite it tells a
complete story within its 24 episodes
it's definitely a mustsee
[Laughter]
that's got to do it for today's rundown
which one of the 20 personally memorable
horror titles is your favorite then do
you have any recommendations let me see
them in the comment section below make
sure to check out the channel for more
topless videos and add a subscription so
you can be the first in line when the
next video drops thank you and I wish
you a great day ahead